okay I wondered around mrs. Lee's and I
both had a look and hopefully this
matches what you've got right colours or
otherwise so you've got those parts
where it's increasing becomes deviation
because it drops down and then it revert
back to increasing all the way okay is
there any indication that is going to
change it's gonna come back around no
that's kind of what the arrow indicates
right it's like whatever I'm doing now
I'm just gonna keep on going okay now
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna use this
too on the graph below work out what the
derivative should be right now I don't
know specifically like precisely what
the value will be but I don't need to
okay over there on that left hand side
let's look at that section with all the
pluses right because the great we've all
indicated with pluses is positive yeah
then wherever you draw your gradient
function it's going to be up here in
this area here why would that be sorry
that's not that's dark enough hurtful
you can see why would i graph up there
why would I for example not graph down
here
what kind of us what do you reckon
give us a thought I don't care if it's
right or wrong we'll know tell me what's
positive yeah okay so come back to our
original function hopefully this is
similar what you're thinking the
original function has a positive slope
and slope gradient is exactly what I'm
graphing down here right so being that
you've got all those plus signs over
there then you're going to be in this
region when we draw okay
now by the same token let's get over
this guy because it's not right when I
transition into this middle section from
here to here okay I'm not going to go
above there cut the x-axis I'm gonna go
down below here can you see why it's the
same logic mean in Reverse right you see
how in this section the original
function is decreasing so the gradient
should be down here in the negative
section and we're gonna finish off by
doing something like this now I'm gonna
let you try and join up draw a graph
onto this second Cartesian plane that
you think roughly represents the
gradient of this guy up here the last
piece of oppression I'm going to give
you is at some places like we've shown
positive and negative and positive right
at some places it's really positive
it's a very large positive value I want
you to figure out where that is at other
places on the graph the graph is
increasing it's got a positive gradient
but it's not a very positive grades just
like a teeny bit okay I want you to have
a think about what graph you would
therefore draw on that second Cartesian
plane have a go shot to the person next
you see if you get something similar
different core misses these right over
if you're struggling or you think heaven
answer some of you have got a shape
there and I wonder how many of you are
kind of like oh that's what I expected
or that's not one at all right what I
expected okay let's think about this
from left to right I'm gonna start over
there on the left most part look at the
original function the one at the top
we've already established that the
gradient is positive would you describe
it on the very left or spot would you
describe it is really really positive or
just a little bit positive on the
leftmost part of the graph I agree it
would be really positive because a large
positive grade we made it's very steep
right which is exactly what it looks
like do you agree with that it's very
steep at that point okay so when you
think about the gradient I'm gonna start
somewhere up here somewhere high because
that's what you just told me a high
positive gradient but then something
interesting happens as you move from
left to right as you track along write
the gradient stays positive it stays
positive bent and around here around
this spot you can see it's still
positive but not a lot in fact it's
about to become what is the gradient we
established it at that top of the peak
it's zero right so in other words the
gradient stays positive but it goes down
to zero now what that means on our
gradient function down here is you start
high where that leftmost blue X is and
you come down because you just told me
it's going towards zero the gradient is
going toward zero you with me okay great
so we have this happening on the left
hand side now in this middle section
here we know the gradient is going to be
beneath the x axis can be negative but
how is it going to be negative well you
notice it starts off kind of not very
negative here it's just gently negative
and then it's kind of like like a
rollercoaster it's like we here we go so
it's the most negative at this spot here
right and then it starts to how would
you describe it
decline is a word you can use decelerate
it sort of slows down a bit doesn't it
still negative still decreasing but by
the time you get to this spot again
what's the gradient there it's zero so
it goes zero negative a little bit and
then back to zero so what does that look
like on our graph here well I'm gonna
say it though as I draw it negative and
then it slows down and then it comes
back to zero do you see that that
matches sort of the motion of the graph
up above okay and then lastly it's gonna
become will have a look
positive right and more and more and
more positive as we go what kind of ref
is that Oh mrs. you have a question or a
thought you're talking about here does
it turn around yeah
does it look something like this is your
question okay fantastic how would we
work out where there or not our gradient
function turns around what would that
mean said that it got a bit louder for
everyone okay
so one strategy would be let's just have
a look at some numbers and test it out
right now that were really helpful if I
had a function I could put some values
into it sadly though in this case I'm
just kind of
I have no algebraic or numerical tools
all I've got is the visual okay apart
from that strategy which would work with
our numbers what else could we do to try
and work out whether it turns yeah
Oh snaps so some of you some of you kind
of picked up on this right we sort of
guessed that we didn't know for sure but
we said right at the beginning when we
thought all three intercepts is probably
cubic right like X cubed of some kind
when we differentiate this we know this
from the rules you should expect to get
something like x squared or 3x squared
or who knows right in other words
something like a parabola
does that ever turn back around no it
doesn't you need another power to have
that stationary point and there's other
ways you could say it as well see how
this is getting more and more positive
does it look like it's going to get
shallower at any point turn around
there's no indication that it is so we
have got no indication that this thing
is going to become less positive all
right now you can see this graph this
page rather has another Cartesian plane
just beneath but if you look really
closely we haven't really addressed this
notation in a lot of detail but I'm
going to introduce you to right now see
how there's not one - there's two so we
very creatively call this Y double -
this is you take the derivative and you
differentiate again just do it again
right I want you to I'm not gonna hold
your hand at all right take that middle
graph think about it in exactly the same
way that we looked at the top graph put
your pluses your minuses work out where
your most important values are see if
you can come up with that bottom
derivative off you go